thank you so let's get started
this talk has an alternate title instead
of on left patent empty it's on on
writing and consuming api's with empathy
because human is hard we'll get a little
bit more into that afterwards but you'll
see that this talk we'll talk about left
pad but it's not the most important part
hello I put this slide at the beginning
of every one of my presentations it's a
bit of kind of a mantra and I'll just
stare at it and that calms me and now I
feel ready to prepare and talk my name
is miles I work for a small disruptive
start-up called IBM I full-time
contribute to the node.js project but I
just want to mention you know everything
I'm saying in this talk is my own
opinion it's not that of my employer so
now that the fun stuff is done and maybe
we should talk about what qualifies me
in particular to talk about empathy so I
have an undergraduate degree in fine art
but you know that doesn't do it I have a
master's degree in music and you know
that doesn't really matter to talk about
empathy either it turns out I can talk
about it because I'm a human being and
we're all humans here and it's an
important thing for all of us so then
that goes on to like what qualifies me
to talk about left pad so I work full
time on node but you know that doesn't
really matter I noticed that you co
system breakage in about ten minutes but
that doesn't really matter I have an
opinion a lot of people have those but
in your opinions don't matter nothing in
particular actually qualifies me to talk
about it so I'll probably talk about it
very little but so what will we talk
about today a brief overview of left pad
a definition of the word empathy empathy
versus sympathy this is an interesting
one the neuroscience of empathy how are
hard-wired to actually experience it
learning empathy because it turns out
just because we're hardwired for
something doesn't mean we're really good
at it or heard of heard for a lot of
things and then we'll talk about empathy
is an API developer and kind of tie this
all back together
it's a brief overview of left pad you
all probably know about what happened
there was a disagreement between
multiple parties a namespace was handed
over to a copyright holder a model and a
module publisher unpublished all other
modules chaos the result the community
grabbed all the open namespaces modules
to avoid bad actors from doing bad
things the version of left pad that
broke everything was republished NPM
changed their unpublished policy to
avoid this happening again the world
kept spinning and hackers kept on
hacking and we move forward this kind of
showed how resilient our community is
and how quickly things can move on so it
kind of asks you know like why are we
still talking about it and so we're not
let's talk about a definition of empathy
so here's a spoiler the term empathy is
actually just over a hundred years old
it's that English word empathy is a
hundred and eight years old that's
pretty amazing you know this thing that
if you went and looked online the
Supreme Court in the United States is
having all these discussions about
empathy Obama's campaign was built on
the idea that we need to be more
empathetic it seems to be in our entire
zeitgeist empathy you know a hundred
years that's not a lot of time the
etymology of the word though comes from
the German word I'm feeling and I think
I said that right or right ish and the
Greek word empathy ax I'm feeling is a
little bit older but still only a couple
hundred years old or like maybe a
hundred and fifty I have to double-check
that but but this is this is a new word
it's a new concept but it's also
something that we've been trying to
understand for hundreds of years and the
Icelandic word for empathy is Sam Kent
that's at least the translation that I
found and it roughly translates to
togetherness and solidarity and I really
like that definition but rather than
trying to define the word by just what
the word means let's talk about what it
means in a deeper way and there's this
fantastic nurse Theresa Wiseman
who wrote a paper about empathy with
patients and she defined the attributes
of empathy as understanding perspective
staying out of judgment recognizing what
the other is feeling can you in
communicating it back it's important to
be able to recognize what's happening to
internalize it and to then you know
bring that back to the individual that
you're talking to empathy is feeling
with people not for people
Theresa then claimed that it's the
ability to empathize which distinguishes
an average nurse from an excellent nurse
in the eyes of a patient so perhaps it's
the ability to empathize which
distinguishes the average developer from
an excellent developer in the eyes of
others and just maybe it's the ability
to empathize that distinguishes an
average human being from an excellent
human being in the eyes of the world
you'll see a few of these there's a this
is a lot of concepts so we'll take a
little break and just let that sink in
think about what it meant and stare at
the cat so brené Brown did this amazing
talk on the difference between empathy
and sympathy and I could not personally
if I wanted to do a better job so we're
gonna watch a video really quickly about
the difference between empathy and
sympathy so what is empathy and why is
it very different than sympathy empathy
fuels connection sympathy drives
disconnection empathy it's a very
interesting Teresa Wiseman is a nursing
scholar who studied professions very
diverse professions where empathy is
relevant and came up with four qualities
of empathy perspective-taking the
ability to take the perspective of
another person or recognize their
perspective as their truth staying out
of judgment not easy when you enjoy it
as much as most of us do
recognizing emotion and other people and
then communicating that empathy is
feeling with people and to me I always
think of empathy is this kind of sacred
space when someone's kind of in a deep
hole and they shout out from the bottom
and they say I'm stuck it's dark I'm
overwhelmed and then we look and we say
hey calm down I know what it's like down
here and you're not alone sympathy is
ooh it's bad uh-huh
no you want a sandwich if it he is a
choice and it's a vulnerable choice
because in order to connect with you I
have to connect with something in myself
that knows that feeling rarely if ever
it does an empathic response begin with
at least I had it yeah and we do it all
the time because you know what someone
just shared something with us that's
incredibly painful and we're trying to
silver lining it I don't think that's a
verb but I'm using it as one we're
trying to put this a little running
around it so I had a miscarriage at
least you know you can get pregnant I
think my marriage is falling apart at
least you'd have a marriage
John's getting kicked out of school at
least Sarah is an A student but one of
the things we do sometimes in the face
of very difficult conversations is we
try to make things better if I share
something with you that's very difficult
I'd rather you say I don't even know
what to say right now I'm just so glad
you told me because the truth is rarely
can a response make something better
what makes something better is
connection so you're going to notice a
lot of this stuff repeated through the
talk because I think this is really
important and the way to learn anything
is through repetition in artistic
practice they call it a practice because
you have to practice over and over to do
something so we're gonna have an
empathic practice today so I hope you
don't mind the repetition but empathy is
feeling with you and sympathy is feeling
for you empathy is about being present
with someone empathy is a choice rarely
can a response make something better
well make something better as connection
another tripping Kati break will let
that sit in
so let's talk a little bit about the
neuroscience of empathy this parts
really cool a lot of these ideas come
from a fantastic talk by Jeremy Rifkin
I've embedded the youtube link inside of
the slide so if you go and find my
slides online you can watch it we're not
going to watch this video because it's
over ten minutes long it was kind of
cheating to watch a three-minute video
it's definitely cheating to watch a ten
minute video but healthy brains are
wired for empathy one such phenomenon is
known as mirror neurons so there was a
scientist who was watching monkeys and
watching monkeys eat peanuts and the
monkeys were all wired up and they were
watching which neurons in the brain
would fire off from the monkey would eat
a peanut and through trouble total
happenstance is most amazing things
happen they forgot to unwire the monkey
one day and on the day that they didn't
unwire the monkey a lab assistant
decided to eat a peanut in front of the
monkey and what they discovered was that
the exact same neurons in the monkeys
brain that fired off when the monkey ate
the peanut fired off when it watched the
scientist eat the peanut that's really
interesting the same part of our brains
are active when we watch people doing
things our brains don't necessarily know
the difference between the experience of
ourselves and the experience of another
person
the Italian scientists that I was
talking about was giacomo rizzolatti and
he was a scientist at the University of
Parma Marco iacoboni professor of
psychiatry and bio and bio behavioral
sciences argued that mirror neurons are
the neural basis of the human capacity
for the emotions such as empathy so even
though we have this word that's only
about a hundred and eight years old the
human race has this isn't something that
our brain just developed well it
probably developed up from time but but
we've been wired for this a lot longer
than we've had a word to describe it
when a baby cries in a nursery and all
the other babies join in this is called
empathic distress the babies don't know
any language to just
a bit but just hearing something else
cry folks that emotion to make everyone
else cry around the age of two and a
half a child can actually begin to
recognize themselves in the mirror and
this starts with the idea of selfhood
and it increases this empathic
development at around eight years of age
a child learns about life and death and
they learn about vulnerability learning
about this vulnerability gives people
the ability to understand hey
not only is there me and is my life
sacred there's other people their lives
are sacred to all these things that I'm
experiencing other people are
experiencing and this helps us develop
the ability of of empathy once you
realize you only have one life you can
now feel others struggle you know that
they have their own life and their own
struggle so some philosophers such as a
scope and power believe that empathic
emotions such as compassion are possible
because we are all part of a greater
ontological whole I really love that
idea a lot of my own spirituality kind
of comes from the idea that we're all
part of this this greater thing I don't
know what that is and I don't know that
anyone really knows what it is but we're
all kind of connected but it's important
to remember that while our ability to
feel empathy may be soft wire our
ability to act on it is a lot trade
we're wired for a lot of things we're
wired for love we're wired for hate
we're wired for hunger we're wired to be
able to learn things but but even just
learning as an example is something that
you need to learn just because we are
set up to empathize doesn't mean that we
know what to do with those emotions
another little break
so let's talk about learning empathy
expressing care for another is not an
innate ability present more naturally in
some people than others but rather a
skill that can be taught and nurtured
through a supportive educational
environment this is from a paper that
you can find at the end of my slides
McClellan proposes that we have to teach
students we have to teach individuals
how to empathize that part of our school
system should be giving people the tools
that they need to empathize with
individuals and it turns out that
empathy was something that I had to
learn so this is a younger me I see
pretty great style I wish I still had
that sweater I was not exactly a problem
child but I wasn't you know the easiest
person to get along with I wasn't really
observant of other people around me and
I went through a lot of life not having
a ton of meaningful relationships for
this and then I met Kristina she's wired
very differently than I am she patiently
taught me how to be in zurvan
she's the kind of person who takes on
other people's emotions and it was just
not something that was natural to me
sharing my life with someone has made me
a better person and it's made me more
empathetic
I personally improve that this can be
learned just because you may not be
great at it today doesn't mean that you
can't be great at it tomorrow and I want
to even speculate but I don't have any
scientific research to back me up on
that individuals who are maybe not
hardwired for empathy as much I believe
that they can learn it with patience and
with love it's important to remember
that while our ability to feel empathy
may be soft wire wired our ability to
act on it is a learnt trait ask yourself
Who am I
who is the other how are they another
how do we relate what do we share and
what do they need from me and I from
them take a second this idea the other
is actually a really important one and
it's really baked into our culture of
the world to think about other people as
an other and not as an ontological hole
we have others in in religion we have
others in nation-states we have others
in that table versus this table but as
the saying goes we're not so different
you and I so empathy as a developer and
how the heck does this have anything to
do with left pad so there's three places
to focus on here the first is having
empathy for the people that you make
things for the other is to have empathy
for the people that you make things with
and finally and it's not always so
obvious is actually having empathy for
yourself so having empathy for the
people you make things for how can we do
that reliability is one people when
they're consuming api's need to know
that they can rely on you not breaking
them this is actually a huge thing and
people can act irrationally when their
things break and this was in my opinion
one of the worst things that happen in
left pad there was a contract and that
contract was broken all the other
emotions all the other pain kind of
stems from this in my own opinion is
people expect when they sit down to run
things that they'll work and that
contract that you have is not broken
performance and you'll notice that
performance comes after reliability but
it's important that things will run on
people's systems and run performing Li
and that it will be fast but again this
should never be instead of being
reliable platform support supporting
lots of different platforms you need to
have empathy for the person running some
random flavor of Linux you've never
heard of
they're trying to run your code too and
you don't necessarily know why or how
and and simply saying don't fix or won't
fix isn't always an answer and this is
always the hardest one but if you're
building software that other people are
using to remember to build for your
consumers and not for yourself
interesting problems are interesting and
it can be really easy to spend all of
your time trying to write the next cool
thing if the people who use your product
don't care about that that doesn't
really help there is a lone inventor
myth in technology and in the world at
times we react as if you know there's
one person who knows more than everyone
else
you know Steve Jobs and Apple is one
example of that where it maybe worked
maybe Linux I don't know I don't really
believe in it myself people know what
they want and it's not really fair to
just go and change things because you're
interested in a problem especially if
people are relying on you listen to them
listen to the people that you're working
that you're making stuff for because
they care and they know listen so how do
you have empathy for the people that you
make things with documentation and this
also seems like something that's for the
people who use your stuff but
documentation is important also for
people who are coming into your project
and want to work with you your
documentation of your process of your
onboarding of your relief strategy
documentation of how collaborators are
expected to work with each other your
code of conduct all of these things need
to be documented not just your AP is
testing without tests people cannot
contribute no one wants to write code
when they don't know that things are
gonna break tests are empathy it may not
seem like it but your tests are a way
that other people can work with you and
get things done onboarding how are you
onboarding people in the first day that
they're contributing to your project how
about the first week in the first month
you can have a ton of empathy and really
help your project be successful if you
can have this outline for people how do
people start contributing in the note
project we have a good first
Contribution label on github that you
can click on they'll give you a list of
issues that can be good to get started
with once they've started doing that how
did things land once they've started
contributing how do they get a
commitment having all of this documented
as we were talking about earlier is
really important but also having
everyone internally agree on this is
really important these aren't the kind
of things that you should be debating
and arguing about when people are just
trying to get started in trying to
contribute this is really important be a
good ally and I would argue that being a
good Ally one of the first things is
never actually identifying as an ally
and we could talk more about that later
if you're interested but being
supportive and therefore the various
kinds of people who want to come in and
working on your project is one of the
most important things that you can do
sitting there and and looking at the
individuals and seeing what's blocking
them seeing what's hurting them seeing
what's driving them away you need to fix
that and you need to be willing to do
the hard things to do that and again
listen to them listen to the people that
you're working with if the people that
you're working with have a problem or
feel uncomfortable there's a reason for
that
and you need to change and having
empathy for yourself and this is to me
one of the most important parts because
burnout is alive and well and I don't
know how many can I get a raise of hands
of people who have felt like they've
burnt out before look around the room
it's a real thing set healthy boundaries
you don't need to have an all green
github chart I mean they remove that
that streak thing and I think that's one
of the most amazing thing and things
they ever did but set healthy boundaries
for yourself listen to your body if
you're tired sleep one of the tricks
that I started doing when I went to grad
school was instead of trying to pull an
all-nighter I would actually just go to
sleep early and then would go to sleep
early and wake up super early and get a
ton of work done in the morning if you
feel like you need to sleep sleep there
isn't any one thing unless you're
working in a mission-critical thing
that's going to kill a human being there
is nothing that's more important than
taking care of yourself be aware of
impostor syndrome I still suffer from it
every single day it's real
easy when you're working on an
interesting and difficult things and
surrounding yourself with more people
who are working on interesting and
different difficult things to just feel
like you're not capable the amazing
thing about the software role that I
would argue may be many other
professions as well but I don't know as
deeply is that we're really just
constantly learning all the things we
don't know you can't be expected to know
everything and at the same time you
can't be expected to know all the things
that your colleagues know that's why we
work together because we all have
different skills stop psyching yourself
out you're all awesome every single one
of you I don't even need to meet you I
know it listen to yourself don't doubt
your gut your gut knows what to do and
if something feels wrong run with that
figure out why it feels wrong if you
don't feel comfortable or something
listen to yourself so let's bring it all
back before we wrap up here well we may
be soft wired for empathy the term has
only existed for about a hundred years
Theresa's Wiseman's definition of
empathy and the attributes are
understanding perspective staying out of
judgment recognizing what others are
feeling and communicating it back this
is not the same as feeling for someone
this is feeling with them you don't even
need to say anything you just need to
understand and be supportive it is
important to remember while our ability
to feel empathy may be soft wired our
ability to act on it is a lunt trait
empathizing requires you to be
vulnerable and that can be scary empathy
is a choice and this is one of the most
important things you have to choose to
empathize with individuals it doesn't
just happen
ask not how am i unique but rather how
are we the same break down those
barriers stop mothering we are all the
same we are all on the spaceship earth
together feel with people rarely can a
response make something better what
makes something better is connection
maybe what you say doesn't matter maybe
the only thing that matters in the end
are the relationships you built
thank you